We all have that one toy from our childhood
we held near and dear to our hearts.
From stuffed bears to action figures, every
child has something meaningful to them that
they clung to.
It may have been a gift from a parent or grandparent,
or maybe it was an old family memento passed
down from generation to generation.
Regardless, those of us who had these toys
became extremely connected to them physically
and emotionally.
Perhaps you talked to this toy like it was
your friend, or clung to it during nights
where it was storming in order to comfort
yourself.
What if these toys were getting the same feelings
back towards us and we didn’t realize it?
It's a question that only those in the universe
of the SCP Foundation could find a proper
answer to.
SCP-174 - Ventriloquist’s Dummy.
It was a normal day for SCP-174 and its owner.
Mary, a nine-year-old girl, has a pretty ordinary
existence for a girl her age.
A room decorated in pink and obvious fashion.
Her school books and art supplies sat on her
little desk in the corner and all of her dolls
and toys neatly sat on the shelves on the
wall.
She wakes up around 8 o'clock for her third-grade
classes at the nearby elementary school, where
she is driven to by her father every day.
She gets dressed quickly in her school uniform,
SCP-174 remembers a long blue skirt, white
button-up shirt, and flat, black shoes.
This was routine, SCP-174 watched her every
day to the point it became part of it’s
expected daily regimen.
Mary ventures out of the room with a quick
“Goodbye” to all her lovely toys, SCP-174
being among her favorites, if not her absolute
favorite toy to play with.
For hours SCP-174 would sit on the shelves
of Mary’s room, staring at the same pink
wall all day long waiting in pure excitement
and happiness for the room door to get pushed
back open so playtime can begin once again.
Mary loved the toy, and oddly enough - the
toy loved Mary back.
Most kids would probably find SCP-174 creepy.
Ventriloquist’s dummies are not often thought
of as cute or cuddly or even good playtime
friends, but Mary didn’t care.
She and SCP-174 had so much fun together that
she didn’t even comprehend the fact that
it might be creepy, nevermind a thought about
what other people might think.
All the dressing up, making up stories, and
living them out.
From brave princes saving princesses to evil
dragons or pirates taking on the seven seas
in search of treasures, SCP-174 had fun playing
along with Mary’s childhood imagination.
Her joy was its joy.
It was more than enough for Mary to be happy,
and in turn, SCP-174 was also happy.
It remembers the day it was brought out of
that dingy attic, where it was forgotten,
left to the dust and cobwebs to pile up on
it over time.
SCP-174 was a creation of Mary’s grandfather,
a now-retired ventriloquist performer and
a master of it at that.
SCP-174 didn’t mind the work, but it wasn’t
loved like it was now, it was just a prop
to be used for laughs and money.
But now, it was something someone actually
cared about.
The glorious afternoon when Mary discovered
him in that storage bin was a day it wouldn’t
forget, as it now felt loved and appreciated
by someone.
Mary didn’t want money out of SCP-174, nor
did she want fame, she just wanted a friend,
and SCP-174 was going to give as much as it
could to her.
As Mary grew older, it seemed playtime had
become rarer and rarer.
It went from multiple times a day, to once
or maybe twice a night on a good day, to once
a week, and now Mary, a sixteen-year-old girl,
didn’t look like she had the time anymore.
Books and papers piled up on her bed from
nights of studying, her attention was grabbed
by her cell phone and late-night calls with
her friends, and on the weekends - when her
and SCP-174 would usually spend the most time
together in the past - she wasn’t even in
the house any more, nevermind in her room.
And by the time she came back, she was too
tired to want to do anything.
She didn’t talk to it anymore, and barely
even looked at it.
At most, SCP-174 would receive a passing glance
and a weak smile.
But at least she still knew it was there,
and that - for what it was - was enough for
SCP-174 to be content.
Two more years passed and now Mary was eighteen.
She had grown up so much, SCP-174 thought
to itself.
It was a cool day as the dusk of summer was
upon Mary’s city.
August was coming to a close and Autumn was
steadily creeping up on them.
But for some reason, Mary hadn’t been preparing
for school.
There was no backpack, instead, a variety
of suitcases and bins lined her room, taking
up most of the space that was previously empty..
Clothes hangers lay on her bed and Mary’s
mother was organizing her clothes into two
piles.
It looked like Mary was moving out.
But that wasn’t true right?
She’s never left without her playmate and
her best friend, right?
After two days of packing and preparing, it
seemed Mary was ready to leave to wherever
she was going.
SCP-174 hoped it wasn’t going to be for
too long, perhaps it's a vacation or a short
school field trip, it thought.
But the fateful day of Mary’s departure
had arrived.
The room was completely cleared out and other
than her pink walls and floral comforter,
almost everything was gone.
Mary popped back into the room, suitcase in
hand, looked around and left without a word.
No goodbye, she didn’t even look at SCP-174.
SCP-174 was devastated.
Months passed without a sign of Mary.
SCP-174 heard phones ringing and faint whispers
of her voice through telephone lines, but
it wasn’t enough.
SCP-174 missed its friend.
On one fateful night, SCP-174 was met with
rings and alarms of the house’s fire alarm
system.
Smoke permeated the air and it began to grow
warmer and warmer, then hotter, then so hot
it couldn’t bear the pain.
All SCP-174 could do was sit there and wait
for someone – something to save it.
SCP-174 woke up wet and charred under a pile
of dirt, ash, and wood.
It could spot daylight through the cracks
and crevices of the mound that pinned it down.
It laid there for what felt like hours before
it heard a familiar voice.
“Mom?
Dad?”
The voice was met with sobering responses
“Hello sweetie,” and “Sorry you had
to see this, we don’t know what happened.”
It was Mary, back from wherever she went and
her family was here.Now, they could all be
back together, SCP-174 thought.
“We have a few things that survived the
fire, your pile is over there.”
Mary’s mother said.
“It’s not much but at least it's something.”
Footsteps grew louder towards SCP-174.
The pile above it grew lighter and lighter
as the face of its best friend came clearer
and clearer into view.
SCP-174 wasn’t met with a face of happiness
or joy like it expected, more one of fear
and disgust.
“Do you see anything?”
Her father asked.
“Nothing I want.”
Mary responded coldly before leaving the pile.
All SCP-174 wanted was a friend.
Someone it could care for and would care for
it.
It tried its best, but now, it guessed that
all meant nothing to Mary.
SCP-174 closed its eyes and with a gut-wrenching
feeling of despair, listened to the voice
of its former best friend slowly fade away.
It was a few days, months, years, or even
decades before SCP-174 re-awoke.
It wasn’t with a new loving family or in
the room of a child who might play with it
again.
No, this was not where it was.
It was in a cold locker, with its only light
being from the slits of the locked door that
kept it contained.
Sadness was all that SCP-174 could feel, and
it's all anyone around SCP-174 could feel.
Its sadness was so powerful, it was influencing
those around it to pity it.
Maybe then, they’d play with it.
But there is no playing in what SCP-174 would
learn to be the SCP Foundation.
The SCP Foundation conducted its standard
amount of research on the anomaly.
They asked the same questions they always
did.
What object class do we give this anomaly?
Initially, they gave it Safe.
It would stay in a box and they didn’t have
to watch it plus it didn’t pose a reasonable
amount of danger.
But would the SCP Foundation be correct in
its assessment of the object class?
SCP-174 was marked as a safe class low-security
object up until May 14th, 2013.
This was a special day for SCP-174.
Well not exactly for SCP-174, but for Mary.
It was Mary’s 19th birthday, but SCP-174
was not there to wish her that.
Its sadness grew and grew.
Maybe if it was there for her she would love
it again.
Maybe if it was there on this day they could
play again.
Just once, just one more time they could be
friends again, and SCP-174 could be happy
again.
With all its strength, SCP-174 moved itself
for the first time.
A doctor later discovered SCP-174 sitting
on the floor next to its containment unit,
looking directly at the main entrance door.
The doctor hastily placed SCP-174 back into
its storage locker, and later, the Foundation
would install surveillance cameras.
SCP-174 watched the entire process through
the slits in it’s storage locker.
Even more discouraging, the Foundation also
implanted SCP-174 with a tracking device.
All hope was lost for SCP-174 to see Mary
again, but it couldn’t forget her no matter
how hard it tried.
It grew sadder and sadder.
To understand SCP-174 better, we need to take
a look at the SCP Foundation’s file on SCP-174.
SCP-174 is a wooden ventriloquist's dummy
with severe damage seen on the figure.
SCP-174 has a number of anomalous properties.
Could it be that SCP-174’s sadness and grief
over losing its friend were so great that
SCP-174 developed these properties?
It’s possible, but the SCP Foundation is
still unsure.
When viewed in a person’s peripheral vision,
it has been reported that SCP-174 will look
at them with an expression of longing or sadness.
In general, anyone in the vicinity of SCP-174
will grow sad or direct sympathy at SCP-174.
The SCP Foundation later discovered that anyone
who places SCP-174 on their hand feels the
urge to talk to the entity.
Those who have put SCP-174 on their hand will
report to researchers that all SCP-174 wants
is a friend that it could talk to.
Those who wear SCP-174 for longer periods
of time will begin speaking in a high-pitched,
childlike voice.
The Foundation believes that this is the voice
of SCP-174, now changing the roles of ventriloquist
and ventriloquist dummy as the person wearing
SCP-174 is the dummy.
The subject will begin to converse with itself
through their own voice and SCP-174.
In all cases, SCP-174 will tell its wearer
that it was abandoned and left to the trash
by Mary.
It would tell them how much it missed Mary,
how sad it was, and how angry it was getting.
SCP-174 learned quickly how easy it could
trick these people into feeling bad for it.
It went from telling the truth about what
happened to it, to changing its story over
and over again to the point the SCP Foundation
has no idea what the true story is and they
have no idea about Mary.
Stories of being left at a playground to being
thrown out or left on a stage by a performer
began to become commonplace.
Anything SCP-174 could think of, it would
use to manipulate the person wearing it.
SCP-174 knows the truth, however, but maybe
it's easier for it to lie and forget the trauma
it experienced.
Is it possible that SCP-174 is becoming corrupted
in a way?
It was also learned that SCP-174’s fake
stories about it’s past will have a direct
connection to the subject that is wearing
it.
So if you remember a time you might have been
bullied as a child, or lost a toy, or anything
that might have been something negative, SCP-174
will use that for its own sympathy.
The loss of its first owner has completely
changed SCP-174’s outlook on life, and now,
it wants to make a friend by any means necessary,
even manipulation.
Through anomalous means, SCP-174 developed
a series of telepathic abilities to further
its manipulation for sympathy.
A D-Class was ordered to wear SCP-174.
The doll’s burned and battered appearance
left the D-Class hesitant.
“Doc, you sure I have to wear this creepy
thing?”
“Please proceed with the test, D-14285.”
The doctor responded coldly.
We know the Foundation is okay with putting
morals aside for their tests, so this answer
should have been obvious to the D-Class personnel.
D-14285 lifted SCP-174 and placed it on her
right hand.
And a conversation with the anomaly began.
“What happened to you.”
D-14285 asked quietly.
“There was a fire,” D-14285 said in a
high-pitched voice, mimicking SCP-174.
“I was at home with the performer that used
to own me.”
The D-Class said, almost on the verge of tears.
“There were burglars.
They broke into our house, my house, and began
to steal anything valuable they saw.”
Back in her normal voice, D-14285 responded.
“That…
That happened to my family.”
“I’m so sorry to hear that.
You don’t deserve that.”
She said in her high-pitched voice.
“The burglars, they were stealing everything.
Gold and jewelry, money, pictures, even pieces
of art my owner painted.
All the memories he made were being stolen.”
“My father was an artist,” D-14285 said
in her normal voice.
“They set fire to everything to cover their
tracks.
All of us were burned, but I was the only
one who lived.
The performer who owned me died trying to
rescue me.”
The D-Class says in the voice of SCP-174.
“He was trying to save me but...
But the flames… th–they… they consumed
him.
Now…
Now I have no friends anymore.
Will… will you be my friend?”
D-14285 breaks down into tears and returns
to her normal voice.
“I'm sorry.”
She says through sobs.
“I’m so sorry.
I’ll– I’ll be your friend.”
The observing researcher begins to yell.
“Cancel the test immediately!
There’s clearly something more going on
here!”
Guards enter the testing chamber upon the
researcher's orders and begin to restrain
D-14285 and remove the manipulative anomaly
from her arm.
The D-Class begins to scream and cry.
“No!
No!
They took him from me, my baby!”
She begins to fight against the restraining
security guards but is dragged out, kicking
and screaming while calling for SCP-174, who
lays motionless in the corner of the testing
chamber.”
It was found the Class-B Amnestics were effective
in quelling the lingering effects of SCP-174,
however, if left untreated, those affected
by SCP-174’s influence and manipulation
are similar in behavior to those of mothers
separated from their children.
Sadly, the tests that led to the discovery
of amnestics being useful in stopping SCP-174’s
manipulative effects were found after D-14285’s
test, as she was terminated due to her not
being able to be consoled and her cries constantly
being disruptive.
Before her termination, the Foundation found
a number of abnormalities in her behavior.
D-14285 would only ever talk about SCP-174.
Regardless of topic of conversation or questions
asked to her, she would only respond with
the same frantic line of questions or statements:
“Is the doll okay?”
“Can I see him?”
“What did you do to him?”
“Why won’t you let me see him” “I
was supposed to be friends with him!”
“Please tell me he’s alright!”
This effect does not persist, as it normally
goes away after a few hours or days.
But in some cases, like D-14285, this effect
will endure to the point of obsession and
depression.
As such, SCP-174’s object class has been
changed to a Euclid level anomaly.
The SCP Foundation deals with anomalies of
varying danger and containment difficulty.
We are familiar with the ones that look dangerous
and act even more dangerous, from SCP-096
The Shy Guy to the employees of SCP-3008 The
Infinite Ikea or even SCP-049 The Plague Doctor
and its touch of death.
But what might be even more dangerous is when
the SCP Foundation discovers an anomaly that
does not look dangerous in the slightest.
Perhaps that’s why they initially placed
an extremely manipulative and dangerous anomaly
into Safe class storage.
The SCP Foundation is known for its cold tactics
and cruel experiments, but in the case of
SCP-174, it was extremely important to test
the anomaly in order to know how dangerous
it really was.
SCP-174 is the story of a toy that was held
near and dear during childhood, similar to
the ones we can all potentially have.
The playtimes and childhood innocence carried
those bonds deeper than we may think.
In the case of SCP-174, it was used during
this period then pushed aside once its former
friend, Mary, grew up and had to focus on
her life outside of the world of imagination.
This turned SCP-174 into a cold monster who
wants that connection and bond back by any
means necessary.
It puppeteers people in order to get sympathy,
manipulating them by using their own traumatic
stories against them, in a sick, twisted attempt
to make what it thinks a friend is.
If you happen to still have your favorite
childhood toy laying around somewhere in your
house, it might be a good idea to go show
it some love.
Like literally - go grab that Tickle Me Elmo
or Hannah Montana singing doll and give it
a hug!
Tell it it’s still appreciated for all the
fun times because well - there may be consequences
to your actions- or lack thereof.
Now go check out “SCP-066 - Eric's Toy”
or “SCP-3108 The Nerfing Gun” for more
anomalous toys you just can’t get enough
of, or that just can’t get enough of you!